everyone welcome Tessa Farias I'm sorry
I'm Jeff and today we're fine outlast
whistleblower what
that's a DLC valise okay um well we did
play this we played this for a Halloween
strand last yeah
the game outlast which came out last
year we played it for like full five
days four days or whatever it was we
play through the entire game now they've
got this to three hour DLC out and for
some reason I'm playing it this game
takes place before the events of the
last game and then kind of ends in over
the top of the last game but you're a
different person so basically the only
thing you really should know is that
it's called whistleblower cuz you play
the guy who blows the whistle on the
whole like freaky outlaw science
research facility operation so yeah and
he's the guy who sends yo character from
the first game a letter saying this [ __ ]
is messed go check it out and fix what's
happening I'm playing this game you
don't have to wake up but it's you slap
that try somebody oh what you I did not
need to say that I'm gonna go my god my
leg is doing that right now
so the mecca of psychiatric system like
they're doing really bad stuff in
mountain massive asylum that's what was
happening in the first game it's the
exact same thing is happening in this
game we're just saying it from a
different perspective
Clint is clear your sight until recently
oh you've been caught so caught
no don't have me committed please
oh no careful like the smoke monster oh
dear oh that was the thing that we
fought at the end about last one no no
get out you [ __ ] idiot move oh look
it's a handycam you might want to pick
that up please don't open me up I like
all my insides inside take around and
our friend yeah all right fine just
don't kill me
no no no I never said no I said yes I'll
do it
no no I don't I don't I don't believing
you'll never see me again
jesus [ __ ] don't wait okay [ __ ] you I
see you you [ __ ] Thanks
oh just making up words Oh making up
slurs shut up
don't [ __ ] bling-bling at me I don't
give [ __ ] you think you're gonna scare
me huh very convincing
[ __ ] Know Who I am yeah I can help oh
oh I'm sorry oh I seem to have caused
problems hilarious [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] balls ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I'm running away
you're running bro hahaha okay he's
doing some salt in that is so fun good
for you mister I would not like to come
play with you but okay how's-how's
soaring okay [ __ ] good you enjoy that
I don't need to bother you at all really
my mouse button takes me Georgia talk
runs in the dog goes up this thing finds
that thing I would like being up here
even though my feet not so on the thing
possibly oh no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no no no no no no no no later later
would be good later he just wants to
show you anything courtesy well thank
you whew that's cool I appreciate it I
think that's I think that's really
really because you kind of seemed to be
doing the hydration you have some way
like to be at the moment can you see my
hands shaking no I'm not shaking I'm not
shaking good Juke that was really good
chick no room in the history the world
has ever been this dog that was oh yeah
you [ __ ] what are you doing to me
leave me and then stop stop stop stop
stop stop no absolutely not I certainly
am NOT going to let me out
no I want yours
you've known me all suvir's I'm good on
the light side of the whole line sucks
walking towards a soaring seems like a
bad idea
yeah let's get the other side the whole
way over that darkened I liked that dark
end don't saw me
eject if it's the cajon running keep
running keep running family probably I
think you what you're doing is probably
for a good reason
hello Wow yeah these look at all the
light out here there's no [ __ ] way
that room is this dog he sounds like
he's getting close I didn't mean to run
into your face burns going for the hug
you and I can work this out we can be
best buds
come on I'll be I'll be your best friend
honey come on love it's good it's good
it's good you need yes he naked find the
room with the guests you can jump over
it is the tip with somebody Oh what are
you joking that is [ __ ] yeah we
found up graininess
I hate you I legitimately hate you
my least favorite person there is oh my
god you want riveted or anything he's
hittin ya oh right dumpster you totally
missed it a lot of the jump scares are
audio because you're not looking in the
right way or you don't have your camera
on all these two guys again she is no oh
it's the dick twins the day don't make
me run and full of chocolate poun oh
don't stab me in the gullet when did you
come from
I don't know he just came out of the
blue I can to get the past because it in
the fall maybe if I am very careful and
slow they won't see me I don't know
about that No
if you have any other ideas maybe
they'll take them but I don't do
anything else I can do but go in here
I'm one of you
we're friends here they tried to bribe
me and I was like no you're running is
this your plan is your great [ __ ]
plan it's sound like they're having fun
and you don't want to disturb that body
okay Oh easy help me no no no I'm not
gonna question it true soul gift horse
in the mouth or a crazy gigantic
cannibal man don't look you in the mouth
either one yet yes not know that's
that's oh good you're riding in blood
that's totally cool good improv I have a
pen if you want to borrow it I love this
song it loops like two seconds and I got
a bit further live day I think I think
that's an electric fence
oh I think so okay they're good that's
our first time here butcher has their
preferences
hashtag jerks gear pumps care wank scare
syndrome turn it off maybe a run foster
I mean the guy turned it back on
Oh actually I seem to be occupied no he
did oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
so I didn't show up your special time
we'll get out of here now I feel like
what this game is trying to teach us is
that ugly people are horrifying
I love either of these corpses on the
ground that have one battery next to
them it's like what are you using that
no there's some grass I can't get around
Oh fence man came back all righty
you got me good good works guy hey you
can make the jump it was not could I run
yes but it's more tense this you a
running start walking sucks really that
doesn't look no get out Oh
oh we coulda told you weren't gonna make
it
no no it's quiet as [ __ ] I'm not sure if
anyone's noticed okay see I miss it yeah
you did
I missed it too man all these characters
in this game is just certain like Oh
what like if I met them in person I
probably want to heat them most of them
are crazy and trying to kill us so that
makes it well yeah I guess
well don't hurt me there
well don't hurt me that okay this is
Gluskin this is where Gluskin is we just
[ __ ] Oh banger eyes oh he's a lady now
oh man I don't want to look anymore so
he's making himself women out of men
unless that wasn't already abundantly
clear yeah oh all right yeah if you want
to see us finish this game I think it's
got like an hour left we can do that so
let us know um otherwise drop us your
suggestions for any old game and yeah
you can always chat to us on either
about Twitter's or by the HOH live
hashtag which we always check and in the
comment section so uh you can if you've
missed any of the stream the full
version will be going up on gamespot so
check that out as well as the highlights
reel which I'll try and get done in the
next few hours but yeah thanks for
joining us thank you everyone don't
forget to check back next week hopefully
see you all then
you